we begin with the breaking news from
Russia it's been revealed that a meeting
has been held between Russian President
Vladimir Putin and the chief of the
Wagner mercenary group yevgeni pragoshen
Kremlin spokesman Dmitry peskov told
reporters that the Russian president
invited a group of unit commanders to
the meeting which was held just five
days after the group marched towards
Moscow last month let's bring in Julia
Chapel valova she's following the story
from Moscow and Yulia there has been
widespread speculation about where the
wagon leader has been since the aborted
Rebellion on June 23 24th what is the
Kremlin saying about it this time round
foreign
well Kremlin has confirmed Putin met
with brigursion five days after the
Wagner armed Mutiny the meeting took
place in the Kremlin on June the 29th
that's according to Dimitri Pesco of the
Kremlin spokesperson the meeting lasted
about three hours it was also attended
by the commanders of the group's
detachments and there were a total of 35
people according to Dmitry peskov so the
the president gave his assessment of
what happened and offered the
representatives of the group employment
options the commanders also presented
their version of what happened on June
the 23rd during the 24th and they
emphasized that they were staunch
supporters and soldiers of the Russian
president and also said that they were
ready to continue to fight for their
motherland so basically that's the
information we have according to
it's a startling Revelation isn't it
Julia what are we to make of the
statement and what reaction can we
expect in Russia
oh wow so it's really extraordinary to
comment on all those things well
basically a person with unique rights
that's uh you're getting progression and
of course he is a person in Putin's
political system so for several months
the country watched the so-called evgeny
pagosian show with baited breath when he
shouted using obscene language shogu
garasimov where is the ammunition for my
Wagner fighters who else is allowed to
do what he's done the man staged an
armed mutant he launched a March in
Moscow shot down several helicopters and
planes killed several Army pilots and
after all that he got away with all that
and he enjoyed the popularity of course
among certain groups including some in
the military and those who supported
Russia's special operation in Ukraine
for a reason he used to say populist
things about numerous problems in the
Army and on the battlefield in Ukraine
rain of course and uh on a Thursday last
week piskov said that the Kremlin had
neither the ability nor the desire to
track preggers movements and we also
heard from President Alexander
lukashenka also last week that basically
he said that he no longer he was no
longer in Belarus so that's uh all we
can say about that meeting but it's
quite funny that the the state media
obviously
um first praised pregocion for many many
months for his
achievements in Ukraine so-called
achievements in Ukraine in bahmoud and
after that he denounced him after the um
the armed Rebellion on June the 23rd 20
uh June 24th so basically how the media
how the state media is going to portray
pregosia now we just have to wait and
see really absolutely that is Julia
shapova with the latest twist in the
story live for us in Moscow